pic à 7,8 millions quand claude tombes
des poteaux à prêcher que quand claude
est tombée des poteaux ils ont perdu un
million et les commandants mais je vous
jure que c'est vrai que c'est sauver
quand claude voilà est tournée des
poteaux c'est vrai que ça a été
l'événement koh lanta on va pas se
mentir et on va pas faire les mollets
les limites aux on n'y croyait pas de ou
fera cette saison de koh lanta et on
s'est tous fait bien avoir et je pense
qu'aussi haut on peut dire des choses le
prof le confinement confinement à jouer
pour kolontar et à l'afrique
je pense que c'est triste à dire mais le
confinement à relancer la saison de
colonna parce que les gens ont regardé
pour garder en famille et un appel un
qui sont dit tiens on va regarder en
plus avec les paysages etc
ça a fait que les gens on a voulu
regarder un programme comme ça on va
revenir sur les moments les plus
marquants la finale où il a préparé un
petit résumé qui résume les temps forts
de la finale de koh lanta
regardez un coût de ces sur les pieds au
centre une merguez saute dans l'eau tu
veux mais vous demandez donc de vous
mettre sur la partie arrière
non
ils ne sont plus que deux sur ses
poteaux le champ s'ouvre pour claude
mais attendu
la victoire pour nawal 2h30
nawel vous vous êtes finalistes quoi
qu'il arrive reste à savoir face à qui
vous choisit ines
[Musique]
non je veux remporter koh lanta
elles sont toutes les deux en hard mais
venez me rejoindre
alors ça a été ensuite mais on va me
faire là on a tout un débrief de koh
lanta on a plein de choses bien sûr sur
koh lanta et c'est vrai que ça a été un
déferlement là on va y aller step by
step parce que vous avez compris
déjà quand vous avez réagi après
l'élimination de toad à ben moi j'ai
jeté ma télécommande de rage
ah ouais notamment pourtant j'aime
beaucoup de nawel sénat formidable jeu
c'est vraiment c'est j'aime beaucoup
beaucoup
la rencontre est à son club de boxe etc
elle est géniale une fille super mais
franchement quand il est tombé j'ai tout
de suite su qu'elle est qu'elle
choisirait sa copine donc je me suis dit
ça y est encore une fois il arrive en
finale
et encore une fois il sera pas il ne
pourra pas prétendre aux 100000 euros
alors que pour moi c'est la vente et
trois fours sims et après trois fuites
mais moi et claude quand je vais le voir
si je le vois un jour ouais c'est pas
possible
ouais je le vois jouer je lui dirai
frères la prochaine fois quand on voit
bien toute l'année tu es que sur des
poteaux
voilà nous cela passe sur un bateau
fiable tu l'as pas sur un pot noter
qu'apple fasse avaler mais ma relation à
puno sud et what's the d'études pas là
toujours sur un point c'est tout et au
restaurant tu es comme ça tu es super
faire ton canaris toute l'année frère tu
es sur un poteau des cammazes super oui
il avoue trier janvier suivi j'étais
évidemment triste mais je suis aussi
scandalisé orange parce que moi je
poussais écorne l'image de koh lanta
s'il ya bien un candidat une saison
ordinaire l'a perdu des poteaux les pas
des poteaux d'accord enfin ils auraient
pu être sauvées par par nawel gafsia
j'aimerais pouvoir vous parler après
déjà c'est votre réaction que vous avez
vu que l'on était tombée jeudi sous
cette règle de faim elles et pour avoir
la chance et forêts savanes a juste fait
d'accord alors justement je suis
d'accord et je leur rends bondi sur ça
c'est estelle denis
ouais mon i stay qui dit cheikh denis
brogniart n'est-il pas temps de faire
évoluer la règle d'atlanta
les deux survivants des poteaux égale
des deux finalistes de l'uruguay bonheur
le répondu estelle ce canon cher estelle
car si tu établi cette règle quel est
l'intérêt de gagner les poteaux de koh
lanta et aurais tu dis la même chose
cyclotron chouchou était tombé doré pour
le premier des poteaux je ne pense pas
je suis sûr que non cette règle c'est
l'adn de koh lanta va te faire [ __ ]
mais toi ton uc
voilà donc après après bien sûr
plusieurs noms d'oiseaux